ein hotel aus eis und schnee das
igludorf in engelberg liegt inmitten
eines schweizer skigebiet auf 2000
metern höhe von außen sieht es aus wie
ein haufen schnee rosa schneider hat den
aufbau geleitet ein besonderes augenmerk
legte sie auf die eiskunst im inneren
das motto tausend und eine nacht
gekommen sind sehr viele romantik
pärchen sehr viele bis eben zu zweit zu
uns kommen deswegen ist auch unsere
kunst gestaltung immer sehr romantisch
und sehr fröhlicher stimmung auch und
die eiskunst ist für uns auch insofern
wichtig weil wir auch schön mit
beleuchtung arbeiten können und auch
schöne akzente setzen können
insgesamt 54 personen haben platz so
schnee hotel
die meisten von ihnen schlafen im doppel
iglu so auch das schweizer paar lukas
buchli und guiliano belgien für 430 euro
pro nacht hätten die beiden auch im
warmen hotel übernachten können
klingt ja nach 80 eiskaut sein
an diesem schlafsäcken uns informiert
wie du dich alter kleidung muss im
schlaf sagt das wirklich waren hass und
war wirklich was ich habe mir geflogen
schnee hat eine konstante temperaturen
um null grad
wir haben auch tieren jetzt in info
eingebaut dass wenn es draußen zu kalt
ist dass die kälte draußen bleibt wenn
man draußen minus 20 grad haben hat man
hier herinnen minus 1 bis minus 2 grad
was man als gefühlte wärme auch
empfindet wenn man reinkommt
von diesen temperaturen ist man in den
alpen momentan jedoch noch weit entfernt
und typisch mildes wetter hat den
zeitplan vieler iglu dörfer nach hinten
geworfen
auch in engelberg wird daher noch gebaut
gerade entsteht das letzte schlaf iglus
mit platz für sechs personen
dann kommen mit schneefräsen relativ die
geschichten drauf also bis zu einem
meter müsste man drauf haben und dann
noch zwei drei tagen geben mit dem
ballon raus haben dann die rohform
können die künstler des bauteam betten
winden und auch eben schön passieren
alles gleich nebenan sind die
bauarbeiten schon einen schritt weiter
ein finnisches künstlerduo arbeitet am
wandschmuck für einen veranstaltungsraum
in wenigen tagen muss er fertig sein
man muss als künstler auf vieles achten
es geht hier nicht nur um das kunstwerk
an sich man muss auf die gäste rücksicht
nehmen und einen guten zeitplan haben
alles passiert sehr schnell innerhalb
von drei wochen haben wir das hier aus
dem nichts geschaffen
am abend reisen schon die neuen
übernachtungsgäste an
80 der iglo bewohner kommen aus der
schweiz manche aber auch von etwas
weiter her
ich bin gerade angekommen frage mich
jetzt kulturschock oder temperaturschock
es toll so was noch nie gesehen
ich war sehr begeistert vom speiseraum
die eiskunst an den wänden ist wirklich
unbeschreiblich
für mich ist das okay
ich hoffe für sie dann auch wer trotzdem
friert trinkt noch einen glühwein an der
eisbar und wärmt sich vor für eine nacht
im iglu dorf in den schweizer alpen